so there's what 74 million Trump uh
supporters voters we can't just wish
them away they're not going to disappear
so then we have to find a way to live
with them even if we think they're bad
people even if we think they're a threat
to everything we hold dear because what
what's the other option that's in front
of us and that's a challenge because a
lot of people will say Well they're
deplorable and we can't find a way to
live with them I try not to group people
the way he does and say that whole group
of people is deplorable that whole group
of people is evil so I'll just talk
about that guy directly he's a complete
authoritarian Maniac what he's telling
you as he's saying we can't really wish
them away we have to have them in
society what he's really saying is we
don't want them in society tolerance
diversity all these things sound good
but then you peel off that veneer and
you realize oh they are actually the
really hysterical authoritarians those
are the people that seemingly would uh I
don't know put people in camps perhaps
they accuse you of all the things that
they are